attention attention New York City New
York the Big Apple baby are you garbage
live is coming to The Gramercy Theater
February 4th baby you're not going to
want to miss it it's going to be our
biggest show yet Army of garbage unite
baby Long Island New Jersey Brooklyn
Queens Connecticut Staten Island fly in
Alaska I don't care tickets go on sale
December 7th you need the early access
code garbage to get them before the
general public use code garbage December
7th get your tickets let's go baby
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite favorite
comedians and we find that the group to
be classy after just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host stage Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at antodi's basement she's upstairs
saying a couple are fathers okay
accidentally ate at a vegan restaurant
last night now she thinks she's going to
hell all right if I co-host is coming at
you from right next to me he is the CEO
of are you garbage he is an
international businessman he's the
prince of Park Avenue but always the
king of the boardwalk baby give it up
for my best pal KJ Kevin James Ryan Hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure your rate of you
subscribe on iTunes full video of Elmo
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage let's go
let's talk about turkey gang check it
out it's a good time over there that's
where the dollar bills hit the road
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
and twos crosses the t's dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone McMuffin it's Toby
McMullen everybody what's up dudes hey
TV yo if anybody's gotta do some laundry
dude on this kid's ABS
tight real tight gang the long hair
ain't lying we could not be more excited
to have her incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time he is a very
funny very accomplished very talented
stand-up comedian actor artist singer
and podcaster you may have seen him in
but not limited to joking off crashing
the nightly show Guy Code versus Girl
Code Night Train ladylike Seth Meyers at
midnight then and now the Late Show
videos ghost hunt laugh tracks comedy
knockout this week at the Comedy Cellar
lights out with David Spade Jimmy kennel
Jimmy Kimmel the comedy lineup on
Netflix he has an amazing podcast which
you can listen to every week called
inside the closet he is currently on
tour right now a lot of theaters in
there the kids moving some Dickies and
he has a fantastic brand new special out
right now on his YouTube page called the
advice special but the big question with
his mind today is he garbage I would
have said no way but he texted ahead of
time and said does anybody have a
charger
we're gonna see how things shake out but
give it up for the one the only Mateo
Lane everybody it was a charger for an
iPhone not a Samsung so it was an iPhone
4 though it was an old charger is there
a Cricket store around the studio by any
chance uh that's so funny though I
forgot it was on those shows that no one
watched it video blows the dust off the
credits really I gotta go back it was
funny guy code was a great show though
the bathrooms here actually reminding me
I walked in it smelled like this reminds
me of the bathrooms from Guy Code it was
like a brief memory of bathroom sink
right here yeah real kitty litter Vibes
in there a little bit yeah but it's nice
to have like it's so Manhattan you're
pissing next to an open window you're
like I'm sure someone's looking at my
dick right now I don't care nice to be
laundry hanging in the back buddy thank
you for coming in congratulations on
everything you're killing it uh give us
the backstory give us the origin story
Mateo Elaine I was bit by a radioactive
spider
bit by a gay spider yeah all spiders are
kind of gays come on
um yeah I I'm from uh Arlington Heights
Illinois which is a suburb of Chicago
right next to O'Hare airport and uh how
close to the airport yeah how close like
next to I mean like a 10 minute drive
like O'Hare is that's close to them so
they flew over all the time yeah and I
remember on 9 11 not to really bring
things down but it was by the time we
start a podcast baby well it was strange
because all flights were canceled and so
we were used to over our house and
nothing so it's quiet it was very quiet
first day you could get some goddam yeah
no my mom's Italian Mexican there's no
peace in my home but um yeah I grew up I
I I'm very family oriented I mean I I
have a lot of first cousins we all grew
up on the same block we were raised like
siblings really okay yeah I mean uh I
don't know I went to art school I went
to the School the Art Institute of
Chicago for drawing and painting I lived
in Italy for a little bit painting like
pretty classy I got a job as a
storyboard artist for fashion ads and TV
commercials which led me to New York and
then I was doing stand up in New York
and yes I've drawn commercials for like
Lexus and seven up and all that jazz
it's like Halston I am I have a little
I'm best friends with Liza Minnelli
selling carpet in my later years all
right go back to uh the neighborhood so
it's near oh here what does your mom and
dad do for a living my dad was a cop
Vietnam vet really and uh-huh all right
and my mom was a school secretary okay
in elementary school your dad works for
Chicago PD he works for in Arlington
Heights okay Arlington Heights Police
were in nam what was the helicopter
pilot get the [ __ ] out of here man holy
[ __ ] follow his autism breaks about to
take over he's just gonna be quoting
stats from [ __ ] Vietnam for the next
what did he fly uh how I I don't know
what kind of helicopters I mean a
helicopter get out right now was it a
huey was it a chinook was it the Cobra
gunship I don't know you can call him
and ask um he was 19 and drafted and he
got his pilot's license and he was like
a med mad pilot so he had to go down and
pick people up he was a medic pod so he
probably flew a huey probably holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] I had no idea he you know
what he does he flies when I was a kid
he we had um he was he was always flying
he actually got his pilot's license he
did the same thing but for private jets
so someone needed like an organ donated
like last oh yeah yeah that's big yeah
oh yeah he wouldn't be on call doesn't
have to retired being a cop and he would
be on call and he'd have to go in the
middle of the night and fly like someone
needs somewhere yeah wait you say
private he knows how to fly Jets too
yeah he does because he kept his pilot's
license for so long he loves flying and
when I was a kid I'd be like four or
five he'd take us up in a Cessna and
we'd fly around Chicago it's cool it's
pretty easy yeah I never realized you do
have the Chicago accent yeah I never
noticed the worst I mean am I around
Chicago yeah his old man was a nam I
don't care how do we talked dude that's
badass that was a chopper piloted
so he had I mean trauma I'm sure you can
imagine for sure and my mom you know she
has her dad is Mexican her mom is
Italian he had five kids with my grandma
and five kids with another woman at the
same time and made them all the same
name so he didn't confuse them so she
was you know back and forth being raised
by her Italian grandparents and then my
grandma remarried a sicilian no longer
speaks to the Mexican family so this is
a lot of drama both families [ __ ] but a
lot of fun my mom's family has to change
my hypothesis what's your dad's
nationality he is Irish like almost 100
Irish Irish American your dad's 100
Irish the Italian comes from your mom's
side your mom's half Italian half
Mexican that's right I imagine she was
probably pretty tight in the kitchen uh
my mom cooks great and taught us all how
to cook when we were kids my brother
sister aren't all in a row so I'm 30s
six my sister's 37 my brother's 38.
they're actually Irish twins they're 11
months apart I got those and we all have
cousins the same age so and we literally
grew up next to each other like my
cousins and I talk every day my aunt and
uncle like my mom and dad and my
grandparents anyway so my mom every meal
she'd cook we'd cook it with her so she
taught us how to cook his kids she made
it fun it was great it was pretty classy
I was getting screamed at
all right all right very good what were
the vacations like as a kid what'd you
guys do well we didn't have a lot of
money so vacations were pretty much I
went to my cousin's house or down the
street right yeah or like my
grandparents or that's pretty much it we
had a house we had a house in Galena
Illinois that my grandpa got years ago
like literally like a tiny house in the
forest so they could go fishing and
stuff okay and so the family would drive
two hours up me and all my cousins my
aunts my uncles and there would be like
18 of us in a house just all sleeping on
the remember that scene The Godfather
where they had the cops sure yeah yeah
so it was like you guys went to the
mattress going to the mattresses yeah we
went to the mattresses and it was just
on vacation yeah but it was a lake house
you'd go swimming in the lake et cetera
et cetera there was there was a lake but
it was just a house in a forest there
wasn't there was no nothing special to
it but what'd you guys do we were just
playing the backyard catch frogs and
toads draw all day cook run around I
mean our parents let us run in the
forest like yeah come back when the sun
comes down we could have died yeah
then oh yeah uh-huh and you say go to
your cousin's house you would just go in
the summer and just spend like a week at
your cousin's down the street yeah
where would your parents just be going
to work if they wanted to go on vacation
like my mom and dad alone oh they would
go away you would go with the cousins
they would be there every day anyways if
we went on vacation as a family together
we went to the house in Galena that was
it so I never did Disney World I've
still never been to Disney World at
Disneyland or any of that stuff but it
was I'd look back now I'm like you know
what it was so good that's why I think
I'm so like I'm not very materialistic
unless it comes to like I don't know PS5
but um except the most materialistic
thing ever but I I enjoy doing clothes
and stuff like that nice cars I don't
know how to dress myself and I don't
have any car or anything about those
nice cars money but yes also it's all
about like family experience yeah they
experience the connection of course yeah
yeah no that's big huh what was does
anybody still live on that street that
you grew up with everyone oh everyone
still lives there oh yeah without giving
it away the name of the street obviously
want to protect the innocent is it like
Avenue Lane Circle Avenue I think
something I have yeah we're talking like
row homes what were the houses like one
floor houses we had we were three
bedroom one bath house so ranchers yeah
Ranch that's what it's called yeah yeah
yeah so you live in a neighborhood or
Ranch houses okay all right with your
parents the first ones to own that house
or it had already been built it had
already been built and they bought it I
think for like 150 in 1980 I don't know
one or something like that 150 Grand
yeah I mean they they just a lot they
just finished paying it off
I'm not kidding you they just finished
like
ma it's been like 40 years
but you know they're very proud they
should be they're landowners yeah yeah
where would they go on vacation by
themselves do you know they either go to
Galena or they'd go to Door County in
Wisconsin
what's that is that the Dells uh no but
I have been to the Chicago hotels or
Wisconsin Dells everyone in Chicago went
to
um it's just like a place like a small
town by it's kind of lesbian-y you know
like chachki and you know sunsets gotcha
they're both from Chicago yeah they're
both from Chicago yeah the vacations are
a little wonky I'm not gonna lie I got a
lot of money this guy's flying private
jets all day it's not time for a
vacation yeah well they you know once my
mom got a job as a secretary then we had
a second income so it was like things
got a little easier I think you know but
still we're not a very like vacate like
going big but now I like it I go to
Italy all the time or I like that I stay
in nice hotels because I'm like
what about the uh the bathroom any
carpet in the bathroom growing up no
carpet in the bathroom uh bathroom had
to be kept clean because you know my
mother okay uh house is always clean uh
we had a brown carpet I remember in my
living room that finally my mother
ripped up and then they got like a blue
carpet and my my yeah we had these we
had these sofas for a really long time
and my Mom hated them but my dad you
know no money whatever we're not getting
new furniture so she purposely got it
she kept getting it dirtier and dirtier
on purpose until finally she was like
look how dirty this couch was like fine
we'll get new couches so no plastic on
anything no plastic no that's mine on
that my at my grandma's house it was the
Red Carpet bright red carpet
um white couches red uh pillows you
don't go in plastic they finally got the
plastic off the couches because my
grandmother said I'll take the plastic
off the couches if I can reupholster the
couch even though no one's sat on the
couch so but my grandpa's blind so he
gets she gets away with anything so you
know he's running into walls she's
reupholstering yeah
my family's insane uh who was your first
car
uh we had I shared a well first my first
car was sharing a car with my cousins it
was a reliant it was a red car a car
with your cousin we would try either my
cousin Megan would drive her I would
drive and once once I got my license and
then I finally got a car it was like a
91 Buick or something my Uncle Mike gets
wet over there everyone's got an Uncle
Mike by the way every their bag has an
Uncle Mike shout out to him and my uncle
Mike sounds exactly like the like like
dot bears like he has a South Side Irish
accent gotta go to drills he so obsessed
with Buicks I remember when my dad's mom
died she had a Buick that she didn't
drive my Uncle Mike's uh Mateo I'm so
sorry to hear about uh the passing of
your grandmother but uh I got what's
going on with the car yes literally he
goes who's getting the car not you yeah
she's not even under the ground you're
like who's getting that Buick because
the garage kept God damn it hey shot
only got a 5 000 miles on it there now
pretty good that's a quality automobile
you got on your hands
he had like six Buicks and then the
Buick he bought my cousins once the
Reliant passed away they got a Buick for
my cousins that was like a Parmesan
cheese green on the side and it was so
humility and the lights on the side like
old people my cousins were so
embarrassed if they were going to a
friend's house or party they parked like
six blocks away like where's your car
it's like farming you know like what's
your what's your pop Drive what was the
family car we had a Ford Explorer first
we had a van and then my cousin's got
the same van then we had a Tempo and my
cousin's got the relationship between
you and this guy true and then then we
got a then we got a Ford Explorer and
then they got a Ford expl
who's who's the there's something's
going okay what they think for
themselves what's happening what side of
the family is this what's that the
Italians the Italian the mom my mom and
my Aunt Cindy that's who it is okay so
it was just one other house with your
cut your first cousin yes yes and where
how far away was your your grandmother
where were they at about two minutes
away not on in this bar for Italians
literally I might as well be three days
they are they they helped raise us it's
communal raising I would say of course
very very I don't know if it's more
Italian or Mexican I don't know which
one it is but it's non-stop seeing
family so it was your mom's sister and
then your grandmother was around okay
um did you drink milk with dinner
growing up we did that's a very but
that's a very 90s 80s thing yeah you
drink your milk with dinner drink your
milk with dinner would you guys all go
to your grandma Grandmom's for dinner we
go to Sunday to my Aunt Cindy's everyone
went to my Cindy's house for Sunday
she'd start she get a cauldron cooking
at like eight o'clock in the morning
make the Ragu and then we then everyone
has to come over so someone has to make
the salad someone has to make the bread
you know the whole thing and my uncle
Mike because he's Irish he doesn't he's
like I'm so sorry but I don't like pasta
is that Cindy's husband Cindy's husband
so she married an Irishman too yeah so
both the sisters both half Mexican half
Italian married Irish guy that's right
so my cousins are all the same mix
what's your Uncle Mike do cop
Chicago did
rocket science what about the Italian
boyfriends and the vacations you're
making the nice pasta and all this stuff
that's so funny I thought this kid was
class yeah he's a dirt bike I could have
had one of my cousins come in here for
this this is ridiculous
you know it's so funny I didn't realize
how strange it was until I say it out
loud like yeah they're both cops both
Buicks they're all driving the same car
they're the same [ __ ] person and both
gay Sons my brother's gay and my cousin
my cousin Brian's game I haven't seen he
had a gay cousin we think that my uncle
my my my Mexican Grandpa's brother was
gay so we think the jeans came from the
Mexican side I just like your Uncle Mike
sitting there like God damn it they got
a gay one now I gotta get a game right
right
Steve you're gay all right
that is a wild cheese I thought this kid
was classy yeah that's a wild backstory
that's the first one we've had cousins
on the Block
that's old identical family to yours
literally but it was great because of
course if I didn't like what my mom was
making for dinner I just walk next door
yeah you plant Cindy or I don't yeah you
know was Uncle Mike and your dad good
pals they were buddies right oh yeah
yeah they work together they weren't
Partners like in the same squad car were
they I don't think they were I mean
Jesus Christ if they were somebody get
this kid a picture
this is crazy it's so funny you guys all
go you go you guys go to church growing
up no we were not church goers really
that I'm happy even with the Irish
Italian and Mexican yeah you know I
think that might be living in there
because my my grandmother was burned by
the Catholic church I mean who wasn't
and they hold grudges too yeah oh yeah
oh yeah if it's something serious I
don't want to laugh but what does that
mean when you get burned by the Catholic
church because she was you know having
she's 18 she gets married to this guy my
grandpa they're having kids with each
other she's cheating on her leaving you
know Furniture getting and confiscated
my grandmother's having a [ __ ] steal
to get them fed and so she goes to the
Catholic church and what do I do and the
priest says have more kids it's like
okay so she keeps having kids which I'm
glad she did hey hi but you know it's
like it was just they they [ __ ] them and
that's your that's your paternal
grandfather right my Mexican grandfather
he wasn't around though no but I that my
mother and him reconciled when she was
in her 30s and then he started coming
around and I met him when I was a kid
and he would send me his name was
Joaquin but he would call him Jack and
he would send me this is how much he
didn't know me he'd send me Big League
Chew for my birthday
meanwhile while you're out there playing
ball sport I was playing ball right
so
so funny I haven't thought about this in
so long probably had to killing it with
the ladies aren't you
that's all right I have an uncle younger
than me because he kept having kids
I do you're trash dude I am I I have an
uncle younger than me because we've hit
23 me if it's a Mexican yeah I don't
care how tight that body gets buddy
you're always gonna be trash man I'm
trash whose sings opera I know the Opera
well uh Pavarotti was kind of trash too
I mean he had Mistresses and extra wives
and you know okay let's talk about Aura
frames Aura frames baby I got one going
at the house talk about a nice little
Christmas gift for me mom and Peapod
those old bags they love this they think
it's NASA technology with the move and
with the moving pictures on it and it's
pretty sweet the girls got the one set
up at the house with all the pictures
and the nieces and the nephews got the
core to fit any style whatever you like
it doesn't matter I got Nudes on mine
I'll fully guys it's easy you simply
connect your oriframe Wi-Fi and use your
free Aura app to add endless pics and
videos you can write invite friends on
the app to have them send new pics and
to your frame as well uh they make it
easy meaningful holiday gifts especially
for the hard to shop for folks in your
life there you go you pre-load with your
favorite photos and you can even
personalize how to have a personalized
message and no need to wrap it because
every box is ready to gift look at it's
beautiful right there slap a bow on that
you're done right now listeners can get
50 50 off aura's best-selling frames
just go to auraframes.com garbage that's
a u r a frames.com garbage these Aura
these are aura's lowest prices ever so
get yours before they sell out terms and
conditions applied do it okay let's talk
about butcher box baby oh I love that
that's one of our faves right there
butcher box game you know what the score
is what's that you go to the grocery
store you're trying to buy meat you
don't know what you're getting I don't
know if they're changing the label sure
is what it is do yourself a favor get
over to butcher box and butcherbox has a
special offer for our listeners butcher
Bach is offering get this new members
two free New York strip steaks and eight
ounce cold crack Lobster in your first
box plus ten dollars off hachimachi
butcher box Lobster is wildly caught and
independently harvest in the North
Atlantic and then pressure extracted
from the claws and the knuckles we're
talking state of the art technology
knucklers they've got over there so get
yourself the most delicious succulent
Lobster you've ever tasted well he
landed that first try butcher box takes
a guesswork out of fighting high quality
Meat and seafood like we've been saying
for years we love them uh that you
mainly raised no antibiotics no hormones
uh like we've I've been saying they ship
they ship me cargo planes full of this
[ __ ] enough of it yeah it's good stuff I
had a ribeye for breakfast a butcher
boxes offering our listeners free New
York uh free New York strips and lobster
plus 10 10 off your first box sign up
today at butcherbox.com ayg and get two
10 ounce New York strip steaks plus
eight ounces of Lobster Claw knuckle
meat free in your first order plus ten
dollars off your first box look at that
that's put your box.com
ayg do it damn this is this is blown
wide open when was the last time you
were at Olive Garden well I went in
August because my friend Nick my friend
my friend Nick wow it's my favorite
restaurant The Olive Garden and I hate
the algros we made a whole video we went
to the Olive Garden there you go and uh
this gay way to recognize me was
carrying 15 plates and they smashed in
front of all of us they fell to the
ground and then uh yeah it was a mess
but it was a very if you want to watch
it my YouTube check out the YouTube but
I win it's disgusting all the pasta was
glued together
horrible we had like seven different
waiters I was I and my food were
sweating you don't know what's going on
it was the only thing that was genuine
was the fake plants behind me I was like
well this is very surprising like you
know give me the free breadsticks and
salad though yeah the salads I didn't
eat the salad it looked wet and it
hasn't touched a breadstick in years
uh what was the backyard like at the
house you guys have a jungle gym back
there a pool anything set no we have a
tree and my mom
go play with the tree my mom had to get
out there and play with the tree we had
a garden you know vegetables and fruits
and uh
um keep the cops away pools no pools
were for like if you had a pool that you
were like something else so this isn't
that kind of neighborhood any pets or
anything growing up we got a dog uh his
name was Hunter he was a pit bull we got
him when I was 13. I love he had such an
attitude we taught him to ring a bell we
had a bell hanging so when you to go pee
he knocked the Bell but then he started
doing it for everything so he'd hit the
bell and then walk over to his food
plate and stare at you or yeah you tell
him to sit and he'd bark at you or like
stop being a [ __ ] but he was great
hunter was great man I didn't see this
coming that's normal though no no
lizards no snakes no frogs Turtles
anything like that Cindy had a dog for
22 years his name was Peyton she she
never touched it the family loved it but
it wasn't allowed upstairs it wasn't
allowed in the living room you know and
and it yeah there was a love yeah
Italian women not do well with dogs
although my mother did well with Mario
okay I'm sorry would they take you to
the theater as a kid or anything like
that the theater no no
I didn't do Sports all right no Sports I
did roller hockey for like a couple
years because I like to rollerblade he's
out there in rollers
I didn't realize how kind of you're just
floating around the whole time kind of
losers in my
you know not a lot of money I love you
realizing that you were well because I
just to me everything was about my
cousins it was about family cousins my
grandparents my aunts my uncles like of
course that was everything and we still
talked I was on a conference Zoom call
with six of my cousins yesterday to
order what are we ordering for Christmas
and who's making the call yeah I love it
would you do The Seven Fishes as a kid
that we stopped doing because I'm also
allergic to seafood and uh my sister was
the last one to keep that going when she
was dating this Italian guy and we would
do You Know The Seven Fishes everything
is seafood and stuff like that but it's
a lot of work and honestly our unlike
Italians because our dads are Irish we
had to do Christmas Eve with our dad's
side of the family my cousins and I
hated because we were separated and uh
and the food wasn't right
um because so Christmas Day we dedicated
to the family my mom's family the
Italians so unlike most Italians we do
Christmas on Christmas Day sure he
called saucer gravy it's sauce okay
the definition of Sugo is sauce what
about the Christmas decorations were
there colored lights in the house fake
tree real tree so we got a real tree
because my dad insisted my grandmother
that I had like himself of course oh
yeah my Grandma had a fake red tree in
the basement
silver Garden Italians always go wacky
colors they go over the top with
Christmas and my mom growing up they I
should call me Aunt Cindy right now and
ask her because they had a tree that was
silver with two hot lights shining on it
of course and you couldn't touch it
because you'd burn yourself
like it's the flag That's crazy dude my
Nana has a uh she has a uh it's a nut
and banana ornament because Italians
love fruit like on their on their uh
fridge so she got a it looks like balls
and dicks so every year we show it to
her like Grandma like you have like a
giant penis on your tree I do not have a
giant penis on my tree
you have to understand that when you
talk but the way I was raised when you
talk about the family like to it's it's
so my cousins and my grandparents are
like connected with my mom and like it
wasn't like just an intermediate there
wasn't just like the five of us it was
like 40 of us yeah it's one of nine it's
the same right everybody's the same age
so when you guys would go places my
cousins are our best friends oh
absolutely there'd be a caravan of cars
yeah two Vans shoved with a bunch of
dagos and two angry Irishmen who
regretted all the choices they've ever
made in life I think my dad thought when
he married my mom that oh it's cute she
likes her family and we can we'll we'll
go have our own life yeah and it just it
doesn't work that way were you guys
allowed to eat in your room as kids
absolutely not okay we ate at the D we
did this I love my about my parents my
mom and dad were like we have dinner we
have it together TV off we sit and we
talk and we have dinner together and
that that I really like and I I I uh I'm
very grateful my parents for racing us
that way that's good that's good all
right all right now we're pulling out of
it a little bit one thing that's all
right dinner together yeah how are the
grades as a kid how are you good I was
not a good student really absolutely not
a good student my brother was a good
student my sister was okay uh but I was
not a good student I didn't care I
didn't pay attention I was just not I
was just not there especially in high
school I mean High School I was
obviously dealing with my sexuality and
didn't know how to communicate that so I
just didn't show up to class gotcha so I
mean I barely passed High School when
did they discover the talent for for the
for drawing oh my mother's an artist
okay and my mother could draw since she
was a kid and I swear to it's genetic
because my brother sister and I can all
draw my brother is one of the top
designers at Apple if you haven't seen
it when when you say the dude can draw
yeah it's like Hanna-Barbera it's insane
we can get a little better than him
I mean Barney Rubble what the [ __ ] I
will say drawing and now that I've so
far removed from it I can't proudly say
like I was I wasn't just like it's for
fun this looks pretty good like I was a
professional
tired professional I've seen them
they're absolutely I saw them like your
Facebook page or something like I got it
you know one of my greatest memories was
because I had terrible grades and I went
to Community College Harper College in
uh uh and near on near Schaumburg and um
I took one class to please my mother
because I wasn't planning on going to
college I was just gonna try and live in
the city because by that point I was
already in the city in Chicago by 16 I
was never home and um it was the art
teacher was also an art teacher from
saic school of the artist of Chicago so
the number one art school in the country
and he looked at one of my drawings he
goes what are you doing here and I said
I don't know he goes you need to go
there's something called portfolio day
at the Art Institute it's like American
Idol a bunch of kids fly in from all
there's only 1700 kids at the school
they're flying from all over the country
they bring their before they wait in all
day long lines and they show people at
the school right and it's literally like
yes or no kids running crying so he
helped me put a portfolio together his
name was Michael help me put a portfolio
together and I went my mom came my dad
my cousins
and uh I had no I'm telling you right
now we're all going too yeah we're all
staying in a dorm room with Mateo
true right yeah
um that's so funny I never thought about
that either you're my cousins came with
me they all got signs
number one it's so true looking for
Seacrest
I got a gold ticket I brought it up I
waited all day I walk up I look I showed
them five of my drawings and the I
remember the lady looking at it and she
like grabbed another teacher they both
looked at it and they all talked and the
sheet of paper you were accepted in the
School of the Arts group my mother's
crying I'm always gonna cry now I'm
thinking about it's great because it
changed my life I was not gonna go to
school I was gonna go to college I was
just I don't know what I was gonna do
and it just I it just completely changed
my life and it was the first time that I
could love school I was a good student I
was obsessed with school I would stay
all day all night I mean it was like I
had to give you a purpose direction
right we didn't because money I didn't
live in the dorms I lived at home so I'd
take the metro downtown every day and
then I still had to work a job so I
worked at Blick art store and I stole a
lot and um
you know it was it was it
single-handedly changed my life changed
my boyfriend life no I got a somewhat of
a discount but I I'm still paying it off
okay all right although I did cheat them
because when I went to your study in
Italy there was a they had a connecting
School in Italy uh in a town called
Monte caster divio and when I went there
when I came back because I was it was so
rushed I forgot to say how much credits
it was so when I got back to the States
it was only supposed to be like 10
credits well I just wrote 10 credits for
each course it was like 45 credits no
one checked I I saved myself like there
you go thirty thousand dollars there you
go oh yeah all right yeah yeah cheat in
the system trash okay okay all right now
we're moving in the right direction then
you come to New York City you get it
after you do four years there
so I was I graduated when I and when I
was 21 and I immediately started working
as a storyboard artist for uh TV
commercials and um I was living at home
and then I got I started living in an
apartment my best friend's Chuck and
Mark in Andersonville and uh just worked
but it was you know the thing with
storyboarding what storyboarding is if
you don't know what that is and
storyboarding is every commercial you
see or every movie or animated film you
see an artist has to frame by frame
design what the director is going to
film or see what angle what they're
wearing
Etc so you know you're basically drawing
a comic book for the commercial and any
30 second commercial can be up to 30 to
40 frames like 30 to 40 drawings right
so it was a it was um you would get the
call like a doctor it would be like
seven o'clock at night your agent would
call you can you do a commercial
tomorrow for DSW for the spring campaign
you know it's gonna be 40 frames in
color uh it's a three-day job so for
those three days you cancel everything
and you base it that's how I became
obsessed with how Stern because I would
just listen to stern all day Richard
Simmons on Howard Stern and I would just
draw you'd sit you would draw I mean to
the point of making coffee four o'clock
in the morning drawing drawing and then
you would finish it and you would get
the money 60 days after and then you'd
have to take taxes out but Chicago
living was so cheap I was paying 400
bucks for my room for rent so you know I
saved a lot of money and then finally my
friend Aaron had a job here in New York
a drawing job and he was like I need an
artist can you move I started doing
stand-up for like five months in Chicago
and loved it and he was like I got a job
for you can you move to New York in 30
days and so I just said yeah I'm gonna
come what will you pull what would
roughly if you don't want to get the
specifics what would what would like the
DSW job pay so if I for the GSW can't we
got my calculator because I'm horrible
at math hence I didn't almost Pass High
School so if I'm doing let's say that
was probably 35 colored frames right
okay so that's 35 and I got I paid 150
for each so that's 5 250 for three days
okay but you take out 25 sure your taxes
and you get paid 60 days later so even
now I'm a good saver I save my money
okay I'm a good money all right I like
the money so you did that then you moved
to New York City so you were making
about that kind of cash you were doing
well when you got here I was doing okay
the job I had uh I I had the I then I
moved to salary so the salary I got I
was what was I getting probably like 60
a year 70 a year something okay so one
check went to rent and then one check
went to just like eating and I the first
apartment I lived in was a tenement
apartment
they had a bathtub in the kitchen in the
village I lived like a Polish immigrant
from 1940.
I had to watch boiling soup all day
all day
I was in the same place I washed my
dishes in the tub the tub in the kitchen
literally like an immigrant from like
1940. just picture everything in Black I
know
speaking Italian and I already have this
look you know I got my hair transplant I
had to comb my hair to the side for a
little bit and I never realized how
[ __ ] Guinea I looked until my hair is
slicked back I looked like the mustache
anyway so you got the undershirt with
suspenders
yeah so um you do have a cops mustache
that's a genetically
then I moved into an apartment with
sashir zameda and Ryan Beck which was
one of the best living situations I've
ever had we were great roommates and I
lived in an attic above sashir so I
couldn't fantastic I couldn't stand up
all the way and I didn't have a closet
so all my I had to get like baskets from
like Ikea and and everything had to be
folded in those baskets and I had to get
like just a mattress on the floor
literally I could I was it was like it
was an attic and yeah and I would I
would basically end up I was just
sleeping so she was bad like her and I
were just asleep but I that was such a
great home because we I I they love so
she loved all my cooking and so she got
an SNL that year and she'd come home
late so I'd make a huge thing of pasta
for me and Ryan and then save one for
her with a note like here's pasta very
sweet we were I mean still best friends
best best friends best friends all right
I like this and we're shaping up then I
lived with Evan Williams and his wife
his ex-wife but uh but we're all still
good friends and she's from Mexico
Felicia is from Mexico so that's where I
really honed in on Spanish in my Mexican
background because we would only speak
in Spanish and watch you know
I speak Italian in English fluently like
you know and then Spanish
fluent proficient fluent like it's I
think you could get us out of a jam oh
yeah no I mean I could tell you my whole
life story but I just sound like Mario
Luigi really because I have an Italian
accent all right three languages my
French is pretty good what yeah 3.5 will
give you if it's French is pretty good
but I feel like you're you're getting
you're I feel like you're grading
yourself on a hard scale yeah and then
German is is it used to be much better
but it's I've forgotten a lot where's
this coming from I studied German high
school I had a great German teacher
haircuts admire and never spoke English
to us he's from
Austria and so yeah you the first day
you're like what is happen who is this
man what is he saying they're just
screaming at me and then after four
years you just like yeah you really pick
it up wait what in high school give me a
couple sentences in German hello
and uh yeah
look at you you've been there three
times in the last six months
again of Pittsburgh and yeah wait this
is from this is from high school German
class
Jesus languages I was I have synesthesia
and synesthesia is this thing where I
like contagious
what the [ __ ] the gay is probably a
little more contagious it's a
neurological thing where your senses
overlap during brain development so I
have like unprovoked association with
letters numbers and music they all have
color to them
so like there are certain like you know
whatever the brain chemistry of the
brain type of the way you learn
languages our way languages and music
tend to be way easier for certain kinds
yeah so you can learn two three
languages you can learn and you know
it's like you it's like doing the
Rubik's Cube you know how to crack if
you plop to be in Greece which would be
great uh for like if anybody out there
yeah
Santorini preferably Mykonos
um I'm kidding I don't do drugs um but
but if you drop me like in Greece yeah I
would probably over the average person
I'd probably I'd probably leave after a
month being forced to learn Greek I'd
probably be pretty good I mean yeah I
just I I enjoy learning language but
I've been to Germany 12 times and I
understood four words you said why'd you
go to Germany my wife Sherman oh my God
that's great you didn't so you don't
learn any German I know I mean I I you
ran through your day I knew what you
were talking about my vocab is pretty
good he's an idiot forget about him
let's talk Greek real quick okay so you
basically you basically have a
superpower do you have any federal on
you
I will say speaking of the other
language does feel a little bit like a
superpower because that is a superpower
and you know what I really like about it
is if you're in a country Spain Italy
Mexico France Espana you know yeah I'm
over Spanish
I'll be going next summer oh you should
go I am I actually go to Italy
um but he can't say nothing I can't say
nothing just stare at the girls
that sounds pretty Italian I can whistle
pretty good really I really I start
groping women I'm Italian
see I'm getting less trashy in my adult
buddy yeah you're pulling yourself
you're really pulling yourself out man
um
I'm scared to ask anything I'm just
going to go backwards yeah no because
everyone in your family still have an
AOL email address don't answer that
but my nana does have a computer that's
never been used they have no Wi-Fi and
it's just a screensaver of stars doing
this she's got an air guest desktop I
love it what was your first concert
Mariah Carey the emancipation of Mimi
tour of the United Center okay that's
pretty good that's a pretty good one
anyone in your family wears Stetson
cologne or Brute uh no we're not big
cologne families actually the guys I
hate cologne I think it's awful okay
let's talk about rocket money oh baby
let's talk about getting jammed up with
your subscriptions most Americans think
they spend around 80 a month on
subscriptions when they actually totals
closer to 200 yeah [ __ ] you could be
wasting 100 each month on subscriptions
you don't even know about you're leaking
cash put your mind I gotta talk to New
York Sports Club
straighten them the [ __ ] out fake Art
Attack gang you could be wasting
hundreds of dollars each month and not
even realizing so do yourself a favor
get over to Rocket money formerly known
as true bill uh-huh the app shows all
your subscriptions in one place and
cancels whatever you want so you don't
have to yep Rock of money uh can even
find subscription didn't even know you
were paying for which happened to me
about two three times shout out to
Planet Fitness
too much you may even find out you've
been double charged for a subscription
to cancel a subscription just press
cancel and Rocket money takes care to
rest easy peasy lemon squeezy here we go
here's the turkey get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com garbage seriously it
can save you hundreds of dollars per
year that I'm talking cold turkey back
in your pocket that's rocketmoney.com
garbage cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com garbage do it okay let's
talk about movement baby
let's talk about another set of guys
shaking up their industry yeah I know
too huh cool watches clean designs
affordable pricing they sent us a couple
I wear that watch all the time you got
the nice watch you wear out we love them
I love them baby I'm a big movement man
they also got eyewear uh and even more
during their seasonal sale with
discounts you can't miss baby the blue
blockers uh like I've been saying I put
it on when I go out when I go out to
dinner with my wife it turns her on I'm
a rich guy with a cool watch over at
galleys
it's Timeless time keeping with a fresh
look movements designs come in countless
styles for every occasion shop with
confidence enjoy a 24 month warranty
free shipping free returns on orders
over 50 bucks what are they doing there
you go uh watches are just the beginning
like we said they have eyewear jewelry
all designated set you apart at all the
right reasons they have the ever scroll
eyewear filter that blocks out the most
intent blue light raises so you can look
your best while doing your work uh here
we go baby be a good gifter with
movement during their seasonal sale get
a special discount just in time for the
holidays join movement today at mvmt.com
that's mvmt.com do it okay any weird
collections Beanie Babies commemorative
plates Coins Stamps like currently or
when there's a family anybody yeah oh
the fam oh I collected like I loved Star
Wars action figures when I was a kid's
toys yeah
um collection any like thing that people
were like this is going to be a valuable
someday don't touch Beanie Babies uh no
I mean we had Beanie Babies we were kids
but nothing look this is the way my
mother functions and my Aunt Cindy if
we're not using it get it out of my site
okay so we didn't have clutter in my
home anybody with birthdays that fall on
a holiday in the family
no Christmas no did I have like three
other family members whose birthdays are
all around the same days me and my
cousin Brian my Aunt Debbie yeah you
guys do joint parties for everybody no
we were kids that we were sure we did
but now it's like yeah yeah it'd be one
cake would you all take turns blowing
out the candles
I've done that no we didn't do that okay
we did all our communion celebrations
together and and yeah there's a lot so
you did communion yeah I did do
communion get a bunch of cash for it uh
I remember uh I remember no like I think
I got like action figures yeah okay the
Jewish kids really clean up performance
yeah yes what was the last book you read
uh I'm currently I'm just about to
finish uh well I actually just reread
friendly with his Metropolitan Life okay
and I was reading uh it's by Larry
Kramer and uh also I uh love um John
Waters I read this twice I read over the
summer and I was reading it again he
wrote a book called role models that I
really love and I love John Waters oh
and if you've not for comedians if you
have not read Wishful drinking by Carrie
Fisher it is [ __ ] brilliant really
yes I Carrie Fisher is one of the
funniest [ __ ] writers ever I'm
talking about self-deprecating I [ __ ]
love her she's fantastic John Waters the
filmmaker right
but he's also the king of trash cash
true that's his name
true all right he's well read
because I don't understand anything you
said in the last 30 seconds I mean he's
got the he's got the travel he's got the
international travel going for how old
were you when you got your passport well
the first time I went to Italy so I was
15 15. to go stay with my cousins
cousins yeah yeah
um and where are they where are they in
Italy and well our family's from
montevago which is north of agricento
but I went to go stay with family
friends what are you talking about I
went to stay with family friends in
Messina and then I would we would drive
over and go see my aunt is it Sicily is
this on Italy it's all Sicily yeah so I
didn't go to Northern Italy until I was
21. it's pretty good though oh okay do
you ever sell anything door to door over
the phone no okay you ever scratch your
back with a fork no I I still when I go
home to my mom I rip off my shirt I have
her scratch my back okay that's okay
getting my back scratched that's okay
does anyone in your family have a
picture of Frank Sinatra or Al Pacino my
grandparents yeah of course was there
was there three pictures in the house as
a kid
uh like the pope Kennedy so definitely
the Pope the last the two popes ago John
Paul where was it John Paul II yeah yeah
not the my grandma hated a German Pope
I don't think that was gonna do that
okay
interesting questions I'm so this is
very fascinating in your family ever
live on a houseboat no okay uh last time
you had fast food
uh I just had Starbucks like is that
fast food no that's oh man you are
adorable
sweetheart oh man you're a sweet kid
Starbucks I got the eggs sausage because
I'm starving I haven't eaten it I've
been running around all day so I just
quickly grabbed an egg sausage McMuffin
thing that's all right yeah yeah that's
okay that's why my friend Nick called I
want to get BOTOX what do I do so no
McDonald's or Wendy's or anything like
that you don't need any of that [ __ ] no
but the last I do love McDonald's last
time I got McDonald's was uh
we got McDonald's I like that Big Mac
over there
actually they do a good job with this
ass I like that Quarter Pounders they're
good okay
but the last time was just been years
sometime this year yeah this year okay
yeah yeah okay but it's not like uh
you're not going
every two weeks no it's too stressful do
you go to the dentist regularly I do you
floss every day no really but I hadn't
been to the dentist in seven years when
I moved to New York and I for some
reason not been blessed with good hair
been blessed with fantastic teeth I've
never had a cavity no braces I did have
braces I mean I look like a goddamn
nightmare but um but in terms of like
cleanliness my teeth are always clean
okay how many suits do you own I have
one whoa I don't like suits I don't like
dressing up I hate Italy where'd you get
that suit I don't even remember uh I got
it at Zara
okay all right that's not bad I went
with Ms cracker a very well-known drag
queen she forced me to get this suit for
a wedding we'll call her black blue gray
dark blue okay what's his deodorant
situation I use like a women's Dove
non-unscented okay all right what's the
soap situation body wash or bar body
wash Dove unscented moisturizer how
often do you wash your hair every three
days every three days do you use product
in it I have to I have topic spray to
make it look thicker I have to
straighten it because I have really
curly hair talk about this hair
transplant yeah okay I got here
transplants you get some sort of
referral deal for getting me there you
can kick back I tried I was like I have
a lot of Instagram followers but this
guy was a good guy and he was like
anyways so like he very like brushed
over it how long does it take you out of
the game for two weeks
that's not bad when was this week
in February okay August 29th so you saw
that you were thinning out a little bit
a lot and I was doing everything to
cover it up I mean just like this is a
sculpture on my head that Michelangelo
would blush at and I you know just
struggling that's pretty crazy yeah but
but you know the hair starts to grow in
after four months so they put the
transplants in it's a 10 hour surgery
and they put the transplant are you out
for that 10 hours well you're not
supposed to but they gave me two valium
in an Ambien I was gone three martinis
on
I I think they had a conversation
beforehand because that's a lot I think
they were like well he's a New York gay
so we have to yeah it's really
juice them up
they asked me to like is there any
balding in your family I said no like
what about your mom's dad I said he's a
Mexican with a one-inch forehead I mean
his hairline starts there so you know
but anyway so the hair now is just
starting to look good this is all fake
trust believe you in me this is
lucasfilm
um but it grows it's real hair yeah oh
yeah so you can cut it and it grows Oh
Yeah
from all around your head it's called
Fue for those curious they don't they
don't do the fut which is where they
take that strip they like now they do
like all over but I went to a very very
good doctor and a couple other comedians
went there as well and uh there's gonna
be one more going pretty soon I used to
patreon.com folks you should go I mean
look do you think they could help him or
is he too far gone let me see let me
bring in a team my hair let me see your
hair sorry you have terminal baldness
honestly mine's about the same as yours
he said his is the same as mine the
[ __ ] guy like this oh look at us huh
let me get in there and that was quite a
few bucks
okay but I promised myself once I
wouldn't need a number once we're all
fair by that yeah yeah I'll share all
that but I promise myself you want to
write it down yeah 9-1-1
um but I said when I when I start making
money I want it like this is what I
wanted to do for myself I wanted a big
purchase and I want to have nice hair
not care about the wind and pools and
this and that so I'm so excited in like
two months from now I'm gonna have a
full [ __ ] head of hair why do they
still have more to do take that YouTube
comment it grows in after four months
because it looks fantastic this is again
the topics or whatever right topic tons
of topics and then I have to straighten
it and comb it forward and hair spray it
to make it look but eventually the
little the little Sprouts are gonna
they'll be long enough oh yeah all right
my hair will look like yours okay I have
a whole bit now that straight men don't
deserve nice hair or asses
wasting it I got them both baby
all right all right here bomb
place you're in now
uh a good place good place I got a good
cover deal and New Yorker La New York
never I'll never live in Los Angeles
ever I won't die here you keep the
butter on the counter at your house no
keep it in the fridge yes did your mom
keep it in the fridge or keep it on the
counter and it was salted kept it in the
fridge we always have butter in the
fridge unless she was making cookies or
cooking for something we had to have it
softened sure interesting any turquoise
jewelry no
I mean we're not from Arizona anywhere
any lottery winners in the family no
um will you play you gotta take out food
will you played it at your house where
you eat out of the containers You'll
Play it I did that last night I ordered
Concho pepper from Piccolo Cucina and I
I took it out and put it in the plate
yeah I feel a little more fancy where
are you where are you eating in the
apartment you eat in front of the TV on
the couch uh no I eat uh on my table my
kitchen you sit at your kitchen table
even you solo even like last night yeah
because I don't want it to get on my I
just bought a new couch so I don't want
to get on my couch so you can never eat
in front of the TV where'd you get it I
have my laptop open I'm watching like
you know YouTube like video game news
sure video games but not at the couch
where did you get the couch uh that's a
great question I think West Elm
I just just redid my apartment this is
the first time I've ever made money in
my life everybody we're right there with
you yeah okay so right so I'm like I
want a nice couch and I want nice hair
and now I don't know what to do now I'm
like I did it
next I don't know where to go what's the
towel situation at the house you have a
full set uh matching towels no I mean I
have just like white towels like large
off my body and some just for washing my
face do you have anything monogrammed no
are you I'm not that big of a [ __ ]
monogram and I live by myself
uh let's go into the bedroom we got a
king-sized mattress queen size bull I
don't miss New York I can't have a full
okay uh how many pillows are on the bed
well during the day I have one two three
four five and then I take them off for
just the two when I go to sleep you make
your bed every day every [ __ ] day
really you got a duvet uh yeah
that's pretty good how many pillows do
you how many pillows do you sleep with
two one Tempur-Pedic and one normal and
I'm trying to sleep on my back so my
face looks less puffy when I wake up is
that a thing it was pretty good
you've been sleeping on your stomach
apparently I've been sleeping upside
down
all the blood's rushing your stomach
what even a harness or something I knew
those doctors were wrong
that scale was rigged
you sleep on your back I tried to I
tried when you go to sleep is a complete
darkness any white noise machines I have
my white noise machine I play uh I'll
play for you now it's the just the
airplane oh okay I like that what's that
like the hum yeah yeah just like the
humming of an airplane it's just this
wait that's it I put on low oh that's
all right that's nice I don't mind that
you sleep with an eye mask yeah I was
gonna say no you have a robe a row I
don't like robes my ex loved robes don't
get them don't like them not comfortable
no and you think I mean it's kind of
like a dress I would love it I wish I
would I want to just wear a caftan in my
later years but um no I don't I have no
roses still on oh whoops sorry I thought
it was gonna be airplanes flying over
like like when you were a kid
we got JetBlue 784 coming in might bring
the cat in
do you sleep with your socks on no what
are you sleeping at just underwear nice
I got a weighted blame any pictures of
that or anything
actually I have tons of me in my
underwear to see them did you go real
heavy on the weighted blanket I didn't
realize it was gonna be so heavy I got
it on Amazon it was like 80 pounds 80
pounds I was like this shit's [ __ ]
heavy I think I got like give me the
earthquake model yeah it's heavy holy
[ __ ] but I love it I want to feel like
I'm trapped under a collapsed Bridge
I'll take the 911 please 80 pounds it's
almost fetish I mean it's so heavy I
feel like I'm just sort of bdsming
myself every night but I [ __ ] love it
a little burrito just like it does make
you feel nice and cozy oh yeah uh when
was the last time you bought a scratch
off lottery ticket never really never in
my life where are you getting your hair
cut at I just got it today in
Williamsburg this guy Arthur does my
hair fancy joint yeah it's a barbershop
Barbershop okay what do you tip your
Barber 20 I forgot to tip him oh my God
I have to I'm gonna put this on my phone
to remind myself sorry thank God you
said that Jesus Christ that'll remind
you
yeah I'll look at him like why is there
water bottle oh I gotta tip Arthur it's
real old country what's the last time
you had a massage I go to my buddies
Steve probably once a month I should go
more often you go once a month first so
I try to I try to because I'm I'm
playing so much back as [ __ ] I'm gonna
go to the gym but he's great he's you
know Puerto Rican Brooklyn gay awesome
we talk X-Men action figures last time I
got a massage yeah
last time I got a massage uh we were
watching Sister Act 2. it's great what's
the cookware situation at the house I
have good cookware okay we have uh
what's it called crew set
I think I do I think that is what it's
called yeah is it the colored yeah like
ideally you know this is the solid color
Yes Yes
um have you ever worn a fedora when I
was 22 and I thought it was hot [ __ ] and
I was dating this guy named Jacob yes he
wore one and I thought I was cool too oh
man that's adorable he's like an [ __ ]
it's tough to not well I've seen some
people look all right in them but it's
tough to know Frank Sinatra in 1940 yes
that's about it have you ever nude
modeled or painted anybody in the nude
of both really I have tons of pictures
of me naked that photography some I'm
sure not real photographers and then uh
and then you're my landlord Steve a lot
of me too has happened to me in 2018 on
Instagram it was great I love those
photos oh you and stavi have great
photos together
tonight did all nudes together shout out
to stavi
um have you had lamb in the last 365
days I have we have yeah like Moroccan
restaurants Greek restaurants pretty
classy um let's
see have you ever been a fan of the show
Dog the Bounty Hunter no
have you had Dippin Dots in the last
365. not only do I hate Dippin Dots I
think they're bird seed I love the fact
that because it was really great America
that was trying to push Dippin Dots on
us that was gonna be the ice cream in
the future and when I went back to Six
Flags a year ago they had scratched out
ice cream in the future in front of
Dippin Dots and I love the idea of the
heads of Six Flags getting together and
then being like guys it's never
happening yeah couldn't get to traction
we thought we were gonna get right
um well you asked to change tables at a
restaurant yes really yeah what
circumstances like me Caitlin palufo I
take her on the road a lot she's [ __ ]
fantastic if you don't know where she's
[ __ ] on the show one of our favorite
episodes shout out to Gary love her so
we'll go to we like woke up we try and
find nice breakfast spots to get a nice
latte I love a nice breakfast right and
by the way I hate lattes that come in a
glass cup it's enough it needs to be
ceramic okay so um I never I would also
agree with that when it comes to food
and coffee I'm pretty [ __ ] so not
[ __ ] classy I like it and uh there's a
[ __ ] empty restaurant with all these
gorgeous booths and we walk in and we're
like hi KATU for us and they sit us at
this [ __ ] table in the middle of the
restaurant with two wood chairs can we
sit at the booth like what is this no
one's here you want to sit at the booth
no I want to sit in the middle of the
restaurant and listen to you clean yes I
want to sit at a booth so we go to the
booth did you say that to them uh and I
say yeah we'd like that that'd be great
I'm very nice to waiters I very very
very nice to waiters if you had if
you're if you're going to die tomorrow
and you had one last meal you could have
what would you get anywhere in the the
world anywhere in the world I would go
to oh in New York or in the world both I
want both in New York I would probably
I would go to Piccolo Cucina Estrada I
forgot to say that word and then eat uh
their lasagna without ancini out in
China's sorry Sicilians and then um in
the world I would go to a place in
trastevere in Rome it's called zumberto
matriciana I it's the best I would just
shovel my face I don't know whatever
that is but throw some garlic bread on
the side
I got Diet Coke there what's going on
that sounded fantastic huh
okay these are fascinating questions
what's the luggage situation
uh in terms of what because I'm flying
every week so like what what's your
carry-on so it depends if I'm doing a
two-day weekend I literally bring a
backpack really oh I'm just so tired of
carrying [ __ ] I don't want you know what
I'm saying if it's like a 40 weekend I
got like a normal carry-on like a
luggage yeah like a roller bag brand bag
that's just Amazon Amazon because it's
orange so that way I'll know it's mine
okay are we flying uh up front always oh
hit me always first class I'm Diamond I
fly here's the thing for people
listening you're a Delta man I'm Delta
I'm Diamond too this is I'm not gonna
make gold yeah I am you're not Diamond
you're silver ah you're not gonna make
gold I'm gold I won't make I won't make
platters so far from time I need eight
thousand I need eight thousand miles to
get the gold and then you gotta get the
Platinum I'm not even close to platinum
let me ask you this does it reset again
every year so what I think this time but
you have to the end of 2023. well the
way they were yeah I'll be Diamond all
next year but then next year I have to
work up to Diamond earn it again this is
what I'll say because people like I'm
sure I sound real high flute and I am
but um when you're flying I was on six
planes last week yeah no it's crazy when
your whole job is flying every single
week I'm on multiple planes it is worth
my investment to be comfortable before I
go perform for thousands of people you
say the same results it's part of the
job you part of your job so now it's
like yes I want to be on the plane first
I want to be comfortable and I want a
[ __ ] meal I never understood why
people wanted to be on the plane first
until I got on the plane first I'm like
this is way better yeah yeah it's just
there's no
mind [ __ ] if I'm gonna get a thing do I
have to check my bag at the gate you're
just on there chilling with a cup of
coffee and I'm TSA pre-check and I'm
clear nice so I melt through the airport
it's good stuff uh will you bring food
onto the plane never I'm not [ __ ]
disgusting that is the best thing look
if you want to bring like nuts or
something or like a bra fine if you're
bringing in a cooked meal on the plane
crazy okay
though that one I know
heck because everybody says it to you
my handsome orphan's Grandma used to say
that to me all the time you're
Underpants
uh when you take your shoes off on the
planet nope not at all the window man
take the snacks yeah I always I'll cause
I have to pee all the time me too always
the aisle snacks of course take snacks
Biscoff cookies okay and I get D here's
the thing because I don't want to
dehydrate because I fly so much and if
you have too much I like a warm drink on
the plane but I hate tea so I get decaf
coffee it's powdered Starbucks decaf
coffee it's not Delta I have no idea
what you disgusting people on United
dude you Jet Blue animals JetBlue
monsters
um but it's great it's warm it's not
gonna dehydrate you it tastes like
coffee it's great I might switch over to
this it's pretty good
have you ever spent the night in a
castle
a night in a castle no no I wouldn't
even know how that would happen this is
one of my earlier questions that I had
written down before the Uncle Mike
situation
oh wait you thought he was he's so
classy at some point he slept in a cat
that's what I wrote last night
I also was gonna ask have you ever been
to a dinner party where a late 90s or
early 2000s R B singer was hired to
perform
to perform yeah no I couldn't even
imagine how I'd get there
have you ever had Negroes I have to
after dessert we have LL Cool J coming
up
that's how classy I thought he was
coming into this uh Negroni of course
okay what's your go-to drink uh I'm not
I don't not a big drink every blue moon
I drink I'll have a glass of white wine
in Italy but if I'm gonna drink it's
either like a bullet on the rocks or a
margarita
um that's exactly why I wrote that
question too have you ever owned a
George Foreman grill absolutely not
do you have things uh what's on autopay
you got everything on autopay uh yeah I
mean there's like bills and stuff yeah
yeah okay besides my rent it's still old
school New York I gotta write a check
every month
um what about the credit cards what are
you rocking you got a anime yes American
Express Miles Card uh-huh nice okay
it has a credit score good very good I
always pay
what's the gym situation I know you're
working out where are you going I go to
Equinox and I have a trainer
oh do you have to meet the trainer at
equinox yeah how many times a week do
you see them five what the [ __ ] four or
five holy [ __ ]
that was one time and he was that good
looking I like maybe he's like I go once
a month well he can work out on his own
damn you see the trainer five days as
much as I can when I'm in town his
name's Diamond Bailey's from Australia
and he's really attractive and really
hates him but he's also a really good
trainer okay everything he says sounds
like a question you should look him up
Damon Bell he's [ __ ] smoking hot and
his pictures he looks like he's gonna
like crush your head and he's like so
[ __ ] sweet like hey Damon how are you
oh I'm just doing good but look I took
the dogs out to die and like I feel like
one of them isn't feeling very well does
he work at equinox or is he a private
trainer he works at equinox you can't
just like bring any Joe Schmo into equal
I don't know what these rich people do I
don't know how that works have you ever
skied in jeans I don't know how to ski
I've never skied snowboard I don't have
snowboard jet ski I jet skied once but I
was riding on the back because my friend
Emma willman's friend Gail had a jet ski
and it was the first time I was on it
and it was horrifying okay shout out to
Emma lover love Emma
um when was the last time you were on a
boat
a boat
um I don't know have you ever been on a
like a fairy
um from the Staten Island Ferry doesn't
count no to go to p-town I was coming
back from a gig in p-town I took a ferry
okay what's p-town Provincetown okay
is that in Jersey
yes it's in Jersey what about in what
about in Italy you ever been on like a
yacht floating around
not a yacht no Cuomo or anything like
that no I don't go to the north uh [ __ ]
I you know what I was
um I stink no no that's like so fancy
schmancy the north are you kidding
they're like Rich
um I was on a you're just saying that
next time you go back with new hair
yeah I did see his house no big deal I
was in it in Sicily when I was like 21
my cousins and I got on a boat with this
old old Sicilian guy hated me and uh it
was but the boat was like the size of
this table and we just were like out on
the Mediterranean like fishing it was
weird so you've been fishing before oh
yeah okay fishing and hunting really my
dad's a hunter but I hated it but I
would go with when I was what would he
go for deer or pheasant or bow and arrow
or gun gun would you go did you ever
hunt and get a deer I never uh no I
never shot I mean I've shot a gun before
but I've never shot the gun to shoot the
deer I was like off in the tree singing
like Sleeping Beauty
but you knocked that [ __ ] off over there
you're scaring a deer away which I said
well if I've watched if I've learned
anything from Disney films singing that
kind of music we'll bring the deer to me
yeah all the animals will come out
um have you ever left the bed Yelp
review no I wouldn't even know how to
how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken from the supermarket no really
this guy's too classy
the whole [ __ ] chicken where are you
shopping what's your grocery store now
Martin Williams they're right by my
house
they have very good uh decent decent
prepared food behind the camera over
there I know I know are you banned from
anywhere no
banned I don't know or have you is there
certain places where you're like I no
longer go back to that establishment or
like you know whether it be a chain like
thrown out of a Fridays or something
like that not thrown out but you just go
like can you imagine what do you have to
do to get thrown out of a goddamn Friday
literally set the place on fire murder
someone and paint the room with the
blood
um no I I'm kind of very New Yorker I
only go to like the same four places
sure you know okay yeah I'm kind of I
mean I'm
for sure thought you're gonna be like
D's tequila oh in Chicago no I was never
kicked out of gay clubs in Chicago but I
used to love they had a place called
Taco Burrito Palace on Halstead and they
knocked the whole thing down for in the
sex shop for some big apartment building
it was devastating it was the best place
ever worst news of my life I'm good I
mean I don't I I'm
I think if I ask anymore I'll just be
more confused as to what
this verdict is what am I like half
class half ever been to carbon never I
would never go to carbon yeah I want
real Italian food that's that's not real
Italian it's American Italian which I
like American Italian food don't get me
wrong but it's not Italian
do you have how often do you cook at the
house I mean now I order my meals
because it's like when I'm on the road I
come back I just want a food microwave
yeah but if every once in a while like
I'll have friends over and cook pasta
okay have you ever ridden mechanical
bull yes I have at my uh friend uh D's
bachelorette party in Chicago
that doesn't really count that's a rare
party
you own a working printer at the
apartment no ever use the business
center in a hotel
I don't think so well do you leave a tip
for the in the hotel yes the maid how
much we talking
um it depends if they come clean now
they don't really clean the room so I'll
leave like you know I don't know 20.
it's pretty good that's pretty good we
buy stuff at a duty-free shop
no yeah I mean like yogurt no that's it
like I meant like the like the duty for
it when you travel internationally
that's what I'm saying if they like if
like just like some quick protein like a
water bottle or something okay but I'm
usually eating on the plane
you get cash back when you make
purchases uh no
there's another one I had from last
night
now granted it's got to be like I own a
dragon what's your dragon's name have
you ever made love in front of a
fireplace unfortunately yes
that's pretty crazy it was it was this
guy was briefly dating when I was in my
early 20s and just oh my memory of that
that's pretty classy yeah it wasn't that
great hahaha
still you did it classy I did do it
anybody in your family claim to have
seen a UFO yes my Uncle Mike that's it
close the book that's it
up with the fireplace Mateo when I was a
kid uh your Uncle Ed and I were out
there fishing I will admit we were
having a couple of drinks and I saw this
thing in the sky and I looked at her and
I says hey are you looking what I'm
looking at and it was this bright of
different colors and it flew away as
quickly I could see years later I was at
a wedding and I was talking to a guy he
uh was working for the military and I
says uh listen uh this sounds kind of
crazy but years ago I saw this thing in
the sky he goes I know that thing I saw
the same thing and I says uh okay and he
goes uh I'm gonna tell you something
I'm not allowed to say it but whatever
you saw doesn't come from this planet
Mateo Lane 100 garbage I love it though
but man what a story yeah that's quite
shocking you're right I did I was kind
of trashy
but with great food yeah that's
fantastic that you can speak a couple
languages it kind of almost tipped you
over but I know I didn't I guess I
singing opera and painting and living in
Italy and so I said my later years in
life that I was just I thought this was
going to be a clinic of like what me
being classy yeah no I guess no I didn't
have like a you ever talk to someone
they say they have like maids growing up
or like their Nanny took care of them or
like I'm like I just think it's like not
in my neighborhood yeah we had Uncle
Mike and we had Uncle Mike we have my I
could call my mom right now and be like
Mom were we poor well they were poor but
you know
fine your vacation down the street I
know ladies and gentlemen Mr Mateo Lane
they're on tour right now you have an
amazing special out yeah watch us on
YouTube at Mateo Lanes called the advice
special it was just it was a crowd work
special but I wanted a Twist to it so I
just called it the advice special and I
literally just asked the audience to ask
me advice and you know gays have a lot
of fun things to talk about sure it's
fantastic buddy one of the funniest you
gotta check him out anything else you
want the folks out there to know uh I
guess follow me on Instagram and date me
there you go can't be what do you got uh
guys we have a couple shows left get
your tickets now uh Boston's about to
sell out if it's not already Providence
is the second show will be sold out
um yeah appreciate it come see us gang
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace